It's great to welcome to the program today,
Roy Germano, who is an author, documentary
filmmaker.
And why you? Professor Roy has some great
videos on his YouTube channel where he, um,
is hanging out with a rabbi, a very charismatic
rabbi in the crown Heights Brooklyn neighborhood.
And so, so talk to us about that role. I mean,
how did, how did that idea start of going,
you actually go to a one night of Hanukkah
with a family in crown Heights. How did this
all start?
It started with the tour that the rabbi gives.
So I live in crown Heights. I live about two
subway stops from where he lives. And I just
noticed that he was giving these tours of
his neighborhood and I'd always been curious
about Hasidic Jews having lived in Brooklyn
for 10 years and also feeling like people
like me and people like him don't usually
talk. So I took my stepdaughter on the tour,
we loved it. And uh, through that rabbi Katz
and I started hanging out. Like we would just
get coffee and talk about meaning of life
and stuff like that. So I'm not Jewish, I'm
not religious. Um, so it was just, it was
just a great experience to, to talk to somebody
that I normally wouldn't be talking to like
that. So one day we got the idea to make a
video of us hanging out and it did pretty
well on YouTube, so we decided to make more.
Yeah. And w one of the things I've talked
about for years is the, the kind of mixed
feeling I have when, you know, I hear that
a, a religious conservative from Iowa, uh,
who has been anti-gay of politically for 20
years of has finds out that they have a, a
child who is LGBT and then their view radically
changes because now it touches them personally.
And on the one hand it's great that they are
not so far gone that a personal connection
can't change their mind. But at the same time,
I wish it didn't require that to be able to
put ourselves in the shoes of others and imagine
what it would be like. So that I'm curious
to start with, did your experience hanging
out with the Hasidic Jewish community in Brooklyn?
Did it change your perspective in some sense?
On any broader social or political issue that
might relate to that community?
Yeah, I mean, what you're describing is rooted
in a social psychology research. There was
a great book called the nature of prejudice,
prejudice by Gordon Alport from the, and it's
really about this idea that it's hard to hate
somebody that you get to know. That's sort
of my paraphrase of, of Alport's theory and
I think it's true. I mean a lot of us have
difficulty imagining what life is like for
others. So to spend time with them at the
end of the day we ended up seeing that they're
not just a member of a group, but they're
a human being and they're an individual and
they have their own differences with that
group and their own similarities. And uh,
you, you can choose to dislike them or like
them on the basis of them as an individual,
not as a member of a group. Uh, for me personally,
I think by hanging out in the Hasidic neighborhood
here in crown Heights, I've just learned that
the people who live there or normal people,
I guess for me, and for a lot of people here
in Brooklyn, you pass Hasidic people all the
time and you just assume that perhaps they
think and talk completely differently.
And then when you sit down and you, you realize
that, you know, we're all just sort of trying
to figure things out on our own and they do
it their way. We do it our way. So I'd say
that's been the number one thing is just realizing
that they're like regular people just like
you and me.
A lot of the realizing that they're regular
people thing in terms of American politics
plays a huge role in the immigration debate
that that is now being had. You've spent time
in, in Mexico, uh, you talk about immigration
a lot. What is the, what are the ways in which
the experience with the Hasidic community
in crown Heights has sort of informed or made
you think about what is happening in terms
of the immigration debate? Right now, particularly
from Mexico and, and points further South
in central and Latin America.
It's almost the reverse. It's my experience
with Mexican and central American immigrants
has that has informed my approach to the hate
crime and an issue here in crown Heights.
So, um, about 15, 60, however many years ago,
I was a waiter in Chicago and I worked with
a lot of undocumented immigrants from Mexico
at that restaurant. And to that point in my
life, I had never met anybody from Mexico
and I had never met an undocumented person.
And so it was like this process of realizing,
Hey, these guys that I'm working with are
just normal people. They're not the kind of,
you know, drug cartel, you know, henchmen
that you see and, and movies. Um, they didn't
fit this stereotype of Mexico that I had seen
in the movies throughout my life. They were
funny. They were kind, they were intelligent,
they were impressive people. So it was through
that process of working at the restaurant
that I started to see the humanity of immigrants
and um, and just really spent a big part of
my career going to Mexico, learning about
the immigration issue and, and then eventually
making films about it to kind of bring that
information back here to the United States.
So this crown Heights project is really just
an extension of a project that I started in
Mexico 15 years ago.
When I look at the conversations that happen
about immigration and politics, whether you're
looking at left or right, there are some that
always come up. What is, what is the right
number of people that should be allowed in?
What are we allowed to do? What should we
be doing at the border in terms of protection?
How much of a focus should overstayed visas
be? Which source countries should we give
preference to in terms of allowing people?
And for me, the big thing that's missing is
the discussion of what is it that is generating
the desire to come to the United States in
different countries. And it seems to me that
actually putting resources into dealing with
that may do way more than any of the other
piecemeal things that are being heavily debated.
What's your sense of that and what are the
broader, broader sort of economic questions
around the issue of immigration?
Exactly. I think you hit the nail on the head
there that when I would go to Mexican communities,
back when I was doing my PhD research, I would
hear the same story over and over. It was
usually something like we used to grow X crop.
Then suddenly almost overnight the price of
that crop fell in half and then people here
could no longer make a living and so that
that price drop that people were talking about
was usually related to larger changes in the
global economy. Sort of the Neo liberalization
of the global economy, the loosening of regulations,
the cutting of social welfare, welfare programs,
and literally the first community I ever went
to in Mexico was a coffee growing community.
And people would talk about how the price
dropped overnight. And when I looked at the
larger changes that were happening, I saw
that that had a lot to do with us foreign
economic policy.
And then later I would talk to corn farmers
and they would talk about the price of corn
dropping. And I would see that that would
have a lot to do with NAFTA and the export
of us corn to Mexico and importation into
Mexico. So I started to get the sense that
if you even tweak small things in our, in
our foreign economic policy with countries
like Mexico and central America, you could
see a vast reduction in the number of people
who are migrating without documentation. And
then the central American case is, is slightly
different because there's the violence issue
there. But you can even look at how our environmental
policies contribute to climate change, which
has contributed to massive droughts since
storms central America. That if in turn made
it harder for people to make a living, which
then has resulted in more people coming to
the U S so everything's interconnected in
that sense.
I want to try to make an analogy between immigration,
uh, in the United States to trade policy as
it relates to China. So we now are dealing
with the, the trade, uh, a war that is being
waged against China. And we hear about, Oh,
we have a trade deficit and Donald Trump wants
to fix the trade deficit. And it's a very
micro focus. And if you step back, you realize
that for decades we've had an economy based
on we want cheap stuff manufactured overseas,
that that's sort of the basis. And that's
a lot of the reason why we have a trade deficit
today. And if we fix the trade deficit, all
of these other things will have to change.
It won't necessarily be good or bad, but it
will have to change and it's not being accounted
for in the same way. The analogy I would make
to immigration in the United States is that
a lot of those people that I see arguing for
the, for the sort of strict right-wing policies,
uh, that, that we've been seeing don't seem
to account for the reality of industries that
are heavily reliant on both documented and
undocumented immigrant labor.
And even if we take them at their face that
these are the lists of things that they want
to fix, there seems to be very little consideration
for the broader economic impact that that
would have. And it's not, you know, you start
to get a little bit, I don't want to start
saying look at the restaurant industry and
agriculture and, and sort of [inaudible] and
uh, uh, PR creating these stereotypes necessarily,
but there's a reality that certain industries
would be very different were it not for the
status quo that exists today. How should we
be thinking about that at the individual level
and how should policymakers think about that?
Yeah. This is actually an area where I think
that there could be a lot of common ground
between Democrats and Republicans. If you
do look at, uh, the ways in which some of
our communities depend upon immigrants. I
made a documentary a few years ago when I
was working with vice news about the dairy
industry in upstate New York and that there's
so many people actually that are very politically
conservative. They're farm owners, but they've
come to appreciate the contributions that
immigrants make to their community because
they know that they can't find people to do
entry level, uh, dairy farming work from the
local community. But there are so many people
that actually have the skills that are coming
from agricultural communities in central America
and Mexico that are interested in doing that
work. And, um, it's just amazing. It goes
back to what I said at the beginning that
it's hard to hate somebody that you get to
know.
You see these politically conservative farmers
becoming over the years, very close with the
people that work on their farms. I met farmers
who actually traveled to Mexico to go to weddings
and meet the extended families of the people
that have worked on their farms for, you know,
10 or 20 years. Um, so in some sense I, I
think that, you know, you have that economic
reality and, and we could come together on
that, but also it's a process of, of getting
to know each other. I think could, could contribute
to, to policy outcomes that lead to more compassionate,
uh, stance on immigration.
What do you think the priorities should be
in terms of what the U S can do? And that
could be what we can do within our borders,
but also we have decisions that we can make
about how we want to work with other countries
that are sources of immigration to the United
States is they're lower. The lowest hanging
fruit that you see that are the, these things
should be done right away.
Um, you know, it is tricky in terms of working,
for example, with certain central American
countries. I mean, there's a huge culture
of corruption in a country like Honduras for
example, where I did some work, but there
are a number of, of organizations down there
that are working to reduce gang violence.
So, uh, working to bolster those organizations
and an invest in those organizations. Um,
there are, uh, various educational, uh, organizations.
Like for example, there's a, an organization
that I'm familiar with called Becca, which
is a, um, uh, an organization in Honduras
that provides bilingual education to young
people. And they've had such a great record
where none of their students have migrated,
uh, illegally to the United States. They found
work and central America. So I think working
with those organizations would be a great,
great first step
when it comes to the economic arguments about,
uh, immigrants are sending money back to their
home countries. And this is a drain on the
United States. I, I sort of have two questions
on that. One is, is it true that it is a drain
and do we not have to account for the other
side of the equation, which is that particularly
undocumented immigrants are often paying into
social welfare systems that because they are
undocumented, they will never take benefits
out and are actually bolstering some of those
systems economically.
Yeah. So I wrote a book called outsourcing
welfare. It's all about the money that immigrants
sent to their home countries. And it's really
is, you know, a massive source of aid to developing
countries throughout the world, not just Mexico
and central America, but throughout the world.
It's worth three times more than the aid that
the world's richest countries donate to the
developing world. So it's just a huge, huge
source of income for, for low and middle income
countries. Um, I do get this question a lot.
Is it a drain on the United States to see
this money go out? Um, you know, compared
to the GDP and the size of the United States
economy, it's really a drop in the bucket.
The amount of money going out. This money
does create jobs. Actually, there's so many
startups in the FinTech world and of course
you have like Western union and MoneyGram
and those businesses that make a lot of money
off the transfer of migrant money.
I do think their fee should be reduced. But
that's just my perspective on that. And um,
and then a lot of times people are buying
American products, even in migrants homelands
with, with this money. So it's not like the
money completely goes away in terms of the
money that immigrants pay into the system.
I actually interviewed the chief statistician
at the social security administration a few
years ago, and he estimates that undocumented
immigrants pay about $13 billion into the
social security system and they'll never see
that money back. And the way that that happens
is that a lot of undocumented immigrants get
jobs using fake social security numbers and
then they're on normal payrolls and they're
getting paid a paycheck. And out of that money
comes the payroll taxes, which go to the,
to the federal government. So, uh, you know,
undocumented immigrants pay all kinds of taxes
as well. They pay, uh, you know, sales taxes
and property taxes and, and all that as well.
So it's not like they're just living off of
the system as, as many people would want to
believe.
I want to touch on one whenever it is that
the current president leaves office, whether
it's in January of 2021 or January of 2025
or sometime in between or before at this point,
it's anyone's guess when it's going to happen.
What are the things that most immediately
should be reversed that he has done when it
comes to immigration?
Well, I mean, his, his effect on the immigration
system is not just what he's done in terms
of hard policy, but it's kind of the chaos
that he's created in the system. For example,
I have, uh, friends and colleagues that work
in refugee resettlement. And for them it's
just sort of an open question of what the
heck is gonna happen, right? Nobody really
knows how many refugees are going to be able
to resettle. So he's managed to just really
gum up the works and create all kinds of uncertainty.
So there's that. Um, I think the wall, for
example, it's just ridiculous. And I've been
saying this for years. I made a video in 2010
that you can find on YouTube of two Americans
climbing the wall and less than 18 seconds.
And I've always called the wall assemble in
the desert. It's just this very expensive
symbol that some politicians want to build
so that they say that they're doing something
about the issue. You could take all of those
billions of dollars and invest that in communities
in a place like Honduras and see huge, huge,
uh, uh, return on that investment and terms
of people's lives being improved. And then
fewer people coming to the United States.
We've been speaking with NYU, professor Roy
Germano, who's an [inaudible]
author, documentary filmmaker. Uh, you can
check out some of his work by if you are watching
on YouTube, checking out the links down in
the video description. Roy is such a pleasure
having you on. I really do
appreciate your time. Thanks David. Thanks
so much.